with the us entering a recession and
inflation reaching multi-decade highs
there's no doubt that the western world
has been on edge for quite some time
many have been struggling to make ends
meet whether that be paying for gas or
keeping up with the skyrocketing rent
even those that make a moderate salary
have been worried as they've seen their
monthly savings go down substantially
but all of this is quite insignificant
to the economic situation in lebanon you
see lebanon has not only been facing an
economic cooldown but a full-on economic
crisis
their gdp growth rate has been negative
for years now and things have gotten
especially bad over the past two years
this has cost their gdp to tumble from
nearly 55 billion dollars to a low of 18
billion dollars to make things worse
lebanon is not just fighting a shrinking
economy but also hyperinflation if you
thought america's nine percent inflation
was terrible just look at this when the
pandemic started it lebanon's inflation
rate roared to 150 percent for a little
bit it seemed like things were cooling
down but then they saw another surge
that took inflation out all the way to
over 200
despite this horrendous situation the
western world at large hasn't really
paid much attention the story of lebanon
has been buried by fewer surrounding the
u.s stock market the fed inflation the
supply shortage home prices ukraine and
so on now i don't blame the west for
ignoring lebanon given how many internal
issues they've been dealing with
themselves but in the sake of telling
lebanon's story here's a lebanon
collapse right beneath our feet without
anyone even noticing
taking a look back it might seem like
lebanon's economic issue started
alongside the pandemic but that was just
the beginning of the collapse lebanon's
economic turmoil can actually be traced
all the way back to 1975.
this was the year that a group of
phalanges decided to attack a bus filled
with palestinian refugees traveling to
lebanon with the tensions already
running hot between these two groups it
didn't take long for this attack to
escalate into a conflict and eventually
a full-on civil war to make things worse
this wasn't just a two or five year war
it ended up lasting at 15 years i don't
think you'd be surprised here that
lebanon was devastated economically by
the time the war came to an end but
fortunately the rest of the world came
to their aid lebanon received tons of
foreign along with massive gifts from
neighboring countries which allowed them
to build up significant central bank
reserves meanwhile millions of lebanese
had found work abroad throughout the
civil war and many of them sent back
substantial amounts to their families
while these were all extremely kind to
gestures looking back it might have done
more harm than good because it prevented
lebanon's economy from truly developing
lebanon became dependent on foreign aid
while its citizens became dependent on
family members living abroad
lebanon further leaned into this
dependency by pegging their currency
with the u.s dollar the central bank
promised that they would always exchange
1507 lebanese liras for one us dollar
this wasn't a very difficult promise to
fulfill in the beginning given that
lebanon had plenty of foreign currencies
rolling in but over time this dried up
you see it citizens with family members
living abroad either passed away or
moved abroad themselves it also didn't
help that virtually everyone who had the
opportunity to leave the country did
exactly that between 1975 and 1990
nearly a million people left the country
and between 1990 and 2019 another 750
000 people left
aside from declining demographics
western countries also started pulling
back substantially on their aid you see
it when the west started supporting
lebanon in the early 1990s the middle
east wasn't really seeing it as an enemy
of course there was the persian gulf war
but the main enemy in most westerners
minds was the russian commies with the
collapse of the soviet union in 1991
however the communist threat slowly
subsided and we saw middle eastern fears
grow and this of course climaxed with 9
11 with middle eastern tension reaching
all-time highs it's not surprising that
western politicians did not want to
continue providing aid to countries like
lebanon it simply wasn't a good look for
their administration to make things
worse a terrorist group in lebanon named
hezbollah were starting to gain some
traction and this basically cut off all
foreign aid banks struggled to maintain
the conversion rate between liras and
dollars and it wasn't long until they
resorted to fraudulent practices
to maintain a pegged conversion rate you
need a strong supply of both currencies
lebanese banks had plenty of liras but
virtually no dollars
now they could have made a lira as a
free-floating currency meaning that its
value would fluctuate based on supply
and demand but given the weak
fundamentals of lebanon the central bank
knew that liras would get destroyed by
the free markets so they decided to keep
the peg and pop up the lira for as long
as possible to accomplish this they
needed more dollars and what better way
to attract dollars than to pump up
interest rates
lebanon would pump up interest rates at
15 and eventually even 20 for
individuals who deposited dollars but as
you would guess such rates were
impossible to achieve through legitimate
means more times than not lebanon was
simply borrowing money to pay these high
interest rates and keep the country
running which led to the national debt
getting out of hand between 2012 and
2019 lebanon's debt to gdp ratio would
rocket from 131 percent which is already
high to 175
for perspective only four countries in
the world have a higher debt to gdp
ratio and the three of these countries
have already collapsed economically so
it was just a matter of time until
lebanon followed in their footsteps but
nonetheless the lebanese government
refused to give in with such a high debt
to gdp ratio it became extremely
difficult to take out more national debt
so lebanon resorted to running a ponzi
scheme they decided to pay their high
interest rates with money from new
depositors and this more or less sealed
their fate as people started to realize
what was happening many of them
attempted to withdraw their deposits
lebanon obviously could not sustain
these withdrawals so with no choice left
in late 2019 they decided to essentially
halt it withdrawals foreign currency
withdrawals were limited to just 200 to
300 per week and this would quickly turn
into zero dollars per week as soon as
the pandemic started technically the
government has yet to give up the peg
with the us dollar so according to
google the conversion rate is still the
same but the real conversion rate is
nowhere near this at this point you have
to use the black markets to make the
conversion and the black market rate
currently stands at 30 000 liras per
dollar this means that the purchasing
power of the lira has basically
collapsed 20x over the past three years
to make things worse corrupt government
officials are trying to run away with
the remaining bank reserves take the
central bank governor ryan solomay for
example he has allegedly transferred 400
million to foreign accounts for himself
and his relatives and that's just one
government official before the crisis
started lebanon's foreign currency
deposits stood at 176 billion dollars
but by july of 2020 this number
decreased to 114 billion
given that legitimate withdrawals were
essentially suspended during this time
period no one knows where exactly these
funds went but it's safe to assume that
they didn't make their way back to the
original depositors
just when you think things can't get
worse they did the entire world was hit
by the pandemic in early 2020 and
lebanon was by no means immune to this
in fact they were hit especially hard
given that tourism accounted for 18
of their pre-pandemic economy meanwhile
the government which was desperate for
revenue decided to implement a whatsapp
call tax the idea proposed charging six
dollars per month to use whatsapp for
calls as you would guess this made
people furious given that whatsapp was
their primary mode of communication
people would begin protesting outside
the government hq in beirut and the
government would cancel the tax within
hours but this was not enough to appease
the crowds while the whatsapp tax is
what sparked the protest there are
plenty of reasons to continue the
protest over the next few days tens of
thousands of lebanese would protest the
government's horrendous economic
policies from making the country overly
dependent on foreign capital to
leveraging a ponzi scheme and engaging
in blatant corruption there was no
question that much of the blame could be
placed directly on the government but
despite their best efforts these
protests didn't lead to anything that
substantial i mean even if the
government wanted to it's not like they
could just pass a new legislation that
would magically fix everything this
crisis had literally been brewing for 30
years so really the only straightforward
solution was to just start over from
ground zero all this economic and
political turmoil was already an
extremely challenging uphill battle but
things would get even worse you see on
august 4th 2020 beirut would experience
a deadly explosion 200 people were
killed 5 000 people were injured and 300
000 people were displaced at first there
was speculation that this might have
been a terrorist attack but this was
actually the result of ignorance and
mismanagement apparently
2750 tons of ammonium nitrate had been
unsafely stored at a warehouse to make
things worse multiple government
agencies had been warned about the
threat of this happening yet no action
was ever taken
at this point most lebanese have lost
all hope and they've been fleeing the
country in masses
mass emigration is nothing new for
lebanon however historic immigration was
never enough for the country's total
population to decline until 2015. since
then lebanon's population has decreased
from 6.4 million to 5.4 million and the
u.n expects that this decline will
continue for the next 10 years with all
of the most talented people leaving the
country it just becomes even less likely
that the country ever recovers as for
the people left in la banana government
has been trying to secure a bailout for
quite some time now but no one really
wants to bail out lebanon foreign
capital is one of the main reasons for
lebanon's current economic crisis so it
makes little sense to hand over even
more capital to the country not to
mention it the widespread corruption
across the government a few months ago
lebanon was able to secure a 3 billion
bailout from the international monetary
fund or the imf but 3 billion dollars is
nothing when it comes to running a 4
country and that lebanon is going to
need more money in no time despite this
dire economic situation many are still
hopeful that change is possible you see
it lebanon had a breakthrough election
in may 13 independent candidates from
the opposition were able to win seats in
parliament but given that their
parliament has 128 seats this is barely
10 percent so there's a ways to go in
terms of creating real political reform
but many lebanese are hopeful that this
is the first step in creating said
change in the meantime the lebanese will
have to continue putting up with the
rapidly devaluing currency
hyperinflation and the loads of
corruption not all with minimum foreign
help hopefully they'll make it to the
other side but my time will tell do you
think lebanon can recover comment that
down below
also drop a like if you're rooting for
the lebanese and of course consider
checking out our discord community to
suggest future video ideas and consider
subscribing and see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one